surprise surprise i want to ask about
the final scene first
it's not a wonder like the end fight
from last season but there are a lot of
complicated camera moves and even
emotional
beats in it so for both of you is there
any particular part of that sequence
that
you found the most challenging or you
were most nervous to shoot
yeah big hyperventilating for a while it
takes a toll on your lungs
i will say um but hyperventilating in
slow motion also takes a toll on your
lungs
um but no no i honestly uh the the part
in the home dojo
was the most challenging obviously you
know there's all this stuff in the house
which was a lot of chaos
and a lot of different moving parts so
that's like you know you're constantly
like thinking through all that
but once we got into the part where it's
just you know me and tori
in the home dojo that was a lot i had to
be playing a lot of
emotional high stakes at the same time
as playing uh
physical high stakes as we we were the
the first two to take on some weapons
how was the uh the training for that
mine was uh i got
i basically got handed a boat staff like
midway through the season and they were
like by the way you're gonna use this at
some point
it's like oh am i cool cool
and then as soon as i was like holding
it in my hand everybody on set became a
baton twirler everybody's like oh my god
in high school
i did uh like flag in high school i was
a baton chair so everybody's like
grabbing the boat stabbed doing all this
cool stuff i was like great
uh i need to learn how to wield that
thing
when you see something like that you
just have to touch it oh yeah especially
because like the one we use like in the
scenes is uh is you know
looks like bamboo and all but the one
that i had for training is like red and
sparkly and it looks like a double-ended
lightsaber so it's so fun
oh same thing with me with the noon
chops they were like all right they're
coming in the writers kept telling me
they're coming in you're gonna learn it
and i said okay guys
when the hell am i gonna learn this
because i know nothing about them i
don't know how to wheel these things
i mean now i'm like it's so fun to do
but i just wanted
more time which is always a theme um
with the with the scene in the larusso
house i think the most challenging thing
was the with the water you have to keep
your energy up the entire time and
my big fight was at the end of it so i
didn't want to mess it up for everyone
else and make them go back
and also a couple sometimes i get so
into it that i actually end up
i ended up kicking the wrong place on a
person and i feel like it just you get
so caught up in the moment and
it's but that's the fun of it too i've
heard that if that happens you just
gotta keep going with it
oh yeah the show must go on and it's
it's kind of hilarious sometimes looking
back at it you can see the person's real
facial reaction if you pause
there's like oh it's it's good it's gold
i might have heard about a couple of
those moments in these interviews and
i'm eager to go back
and see if i can pinpoint that frame
somewhere yeah one last one before i
leave you guys peyton
uh i am very curious to know where you
think tory's head is at
in the end because even though she has
crease and the remainder of cobra kai
having lost aisha miguel now
hawk is she kind of in a more lonesome
place than ever in your mind i think so
i think the closer she goes to crease
and cobra kai
the further she gets away from her
friends and everything now i think it's
i think it's more lonely
um and that was where she started to
lose me because i always understood
and that was where i started to go okay
now i don't know where we're going but
this is a
worse place than ever i feel bad now i
i you know and i think it's gonna get
i'm going more towards villain territory
every
every episode i think